last week the clock stopped for two
extraordinary Americans one a former war
hero and Senator John McCain the other
the Queen of Soul both lay in state for
days and days
McCain's was a somber affair suited to
the capital of the world Aretha
Franklin's was colorful and glamorous
the star wearing a red dress and
five-inch stilettos in an open casket in
Motown some have copped about the
excessive remembrance thing given the
funeral seemed to go on for longer than
the Jurassic period
okay I exaggerated Franklin's
live-streamed send-off was a snappy
eight hours not I I say our espec teens
respect it is only right and fitting
that we take time out together to mark
the passing of those who are truly great
or tragedy one minute silences at
football matches on Remembrance Day the
way the Notting Hill Carnival stopped to
recall the grin for fire the funerals of
great Americans these pauses in everyday
life remind us we are united by our
mortality these are uncertain and angry
times such moments of international
communion help find us together I want
you to do that respect I sort of agree
with you but I think you I think
something happened in this country that
I think took it that kind of grieving
that kind of worshipping over the top
and we know what I'm talking about is
the death of Princess Diana yes it kind
of spawned armies of grief junkies you
know people anything and wailing and
crying you know I think absolutely John
McCain absolutely afforded respect you
know the guy you know I wouldn't be
weeping and waving over his death but
but I mourn the loss of such a man I
would be sad about that under Risa
Franklin and but it but I don't think
it's interesting what's happened to this
country we have become you know there's
a think tank called air Civitas and they
this guy called Pat of West wrote a
report in 2012
and he was saying he called this stuff
ostentatious caring he called it a
flight and he said it's it's he said
this has been triggered by the decline
of institutions that gave people's lives
meaning institutions like family like
church like neighborhood and when you
think in the result of that has been
that you know we don't do things that we
would have done 20 years ago
naturally for instance you know people
that you know 20 years ago you'd knock
on your elderly neighbor's door and said
in the supermarket everybody all the
time offering a button they don't do
that well should we show a distinction
between the ostentatious public grieving
for people we don't know and let me just
finish the point on that because I think
we've lost our instinct okay as a
society what happens is when something
big like a death like over it's overkill
and you know it's like it's it's almost
like we you know we want to reconnect it
where it's like a lonely society that's
trying to reconnect as I said um you you
used to run the FO do you not think and
of course it is obviously you want to
show respect but there are too many
minute silence it's a football mentioned
they've somewhat lost there and I don't
mean this in a derogatory fashion but
you know that the second assistant
groundsman sadly dies so the whole
ground the whole team I do think you do
get if you if you support a particular
side and people that have played and
you've watched the you've been part of
the and they've been your heroes I think
it's perfectly valid to - you don't
think they've been a respect show you
respect I think yeah and this tweets
probably a little bit a little bit
overboard but I'm gonna read you anyway
so many people are crying or in bits
over paui you you are not ten you an
adult man got say something interesting
now that's a bit excessive but listen
okay stiff upper lip is a thing you know
we lightly Pratt and I've stood by many
a gravesite unfortunately you know in my
time in the military okay
respect me as we shown it's it's thing
where people seem to carry it on and on
and on you know this
you've gotta grieve in your own in your
own space and show you respect in public
PRV is selling itself now by the way on
it's ok to cry it's ok to say and I do
say it's ok so ok either I've a little
group called is ok to say and I'm
encouraging guys to come two people a
day or ok to say well they've got
problems it's ok I don't have I don't
have a drop of that ok but when you've
got this mass going on - it isn't isn't
it you know where you look on Twitter
and social various social medias
different bits yeah and there's people
every week saying I'm devastated the
same people think I'm devastated I feel
your pain now you don't feel that pain
it does rubbish but you know the Diana
grieving I mean let's have a look let's
have a look at a clip here this is
Dickie Abba and who used to work for for
the Royals listen what he has to say
I suppose an outpouring was expected
that it was so big amazed everybody and
I remember the first bunch of flowers
was laid at the centre gates of
Buckingham Palace and about 5 to 5 in
the morning the sight of these crowds go
on the streets I found it compelling and
people mock it now thinking some kind of
madness overcame us there was a
collective psychotic episode or the
country went hysterical in those few
days I have to tell you at the time it
didn't feel like that it felt like
something much more admirable actually
it was a very gentle almost tender
hemisphere he says that but now I
covered that story obviously was 21
years ago and my experience I had
written a column two days before she
died and and I criticized her for being
involved in politics
Royals then wasn't as they are now and
the paper when she died forgot to pull
the column and so so I got I got so many
death threats I had to have a guard a
bodyguard security guard for three
months then you know I had to park under
the building I wasn't allowed to walk in
there because people wanted to kill me I
mean they didn't understand change there
between I think everyone was surprised
by that how with the Diana vacation to
remember our own emotion that it became
competitive morning that's it so that
when that terrible day when you saw the
hearse driving up the ankle showing
roses my own father actually walked out
of through and walked past and he was
stood on a bridge and he watched the
cortege going out and my stepmother
didn't have the same feelings and kind
of find his crying rather rude it was a
watershed Rachel yes mate long long be a
long long long long way away but as and
when we lose the Queen will there be the
same level of outpouring was it driven
because Dinah was so young a life taken
so young I think of course I mean when
the Queen dies she's in her 90s I think
it will be there will be a convulsion
again but I think the plan succession as
we know the bridge operation is is you
know I think it's going to be very well
managed it's going to be incredibly
moving
she's the youth usually be quiet about
it and I think a lot of people's grief
over time well go on a nice day way yeah
and I say this respectfully was more
about them than her because I think she
eyed people identified with her
sadnesses I think they identified with
the fact she was a young mom they
identified with the trauma so in a way
day 37
their grief was more about then than
about her because they didn't know her
they might get back to the hookman point
of the queue which was I think that we
all have these hectic lives me
increasingly less so yes I noticed that
what I think these moments servers we
don't go to church as Carol said so much
we don't we'd have time to see our
families are all scattered these are
moments when it's where the human family
gathers and it's it and we take time I
look at Twitter it's a bit that's in it
which means despair it's not real I'm
not related to it frankly we can all
stop and think what did she do what was
her legacy what is our legacy as you
sort of have this amplifying a lot of
stuff
fact that has her funeral is live
streamed who hasn't had that do you like
these moments where we all stop
Remembrance Sunday I think it's the same
it's remember that's what I was trying
to say I fear if you do it too often
they lose their but it's interesting if
you look at the funerals you go to and
you know I'm a valet driver funerals we
go to because we've got to move on I'm
sorry Greg again now we're all used to
Donald Trump's saying it how it is or at
least how he sees it but this week it's
not the president who's hitting the
headlines because of comments he's made
but an anonymous White House senior aide
a sensational account of life and the
most powerful administration in the
world has been published by the New York
Times and it doesn't make for reassuring
reading senior officials will privately
admit their daily disbelief at the
commander-in-chief's comments and
actions the aide writes most are working
to insulate their operations from his
whims meetings with him very often off
the rails he engages in repetitive rants
in his impulsiveness results in
half-baked ill-informed and occasionally
reckless decisions that have to be
walked back sounds like an episode of
the pledge your candid revelations
whoever you are you are most certainly a
straight talker of the week yeah but he
hasn't actually told us something we
didn't know was it no I thought we're
gonna talk about the Bob Woodward book
as well no it's not that's gonna be very
damaging to him my brother about
funerals I have more respect for this
so-called straight or who actually
needed he or she was get winded it's
like in your game army top brass they
always say how paralyzed is how they
have no money
once they've retired all the time
they're actually imposed everything's
fantastic will make the minute they step
out and take the pension then of course
the army hasn't got enough money to put
soldiers on the streets